down
[Music]
hello to
the sparse remaining group uh we'll have
a
uh the final talk of the afternoon by
sarkon helsin
on symmetry adapter graham specker
thank you
uh hi everyone uh thanks for being here
on this beautiful day i can see uh you
can do other things i'm being here and
then uh and listening to talk but uh i'm
glad it's gonna be a short talk scott 30
minutes and maybe we can even do it
faster we'll see okay but on the other
hand i'll uh you know please interrupt
me you know i'd rather have you so if i
really get it then then going you know
fast through this
um so yeah my name is cyclone host and
i'm from just across the bay san
francisco state university and what i'm
going to talk to you today is
joint work with two sets of people
um
alex heaton and izabel shankar
um the the work has already appeared
um in the shorter version actually the
archive version is
more
expanded you know if you want to check
that out
and uh so alex and alex was a postdoc at
mpi leipzig and we were doing this and
isabelle was a
phd student here in uc berkeley um they
moved to their respective
next jobs as a tenure track
um system prof and and postdoctors uh
uh accordingly and then matthew hyde was
a master student at san francisco state
and then this was his master's thesis
that we did together
so um
you know this is a part of the
optimization workshop just let me remind
you a few things if you're doing
polynomial optimization are you a
polynomial with real coefficients
in n variables and you're trying to
minimize you know you use it as an
objective function uh we all know that
is a very very hard problem
but uh one way of formulating is of
course instead of minimizing the
polynomial function
right you you try to maximize the
uh sort of a lower bound so that the
difference is between the lower bound
and the
and the polynomial is non-negative
that's still hard we didn't do anything
new
uh but we can relax it right instead of
asking that polynomial to be
non-negative we can ask whether it's a
sum of squares polynomial
right so a polynomial sum of squares
if it can be written the real polynomial
is sum of squares if it can be written
as a sum of squares of other polynomials
that's obviously non-negative right
so
that that the relaxation is is easier
um and it depends on the following
observation it's a classical
uh any polynomial p in n variables i
wrote it as p alpha x squared alpha
so x to the alpha is a monomial
right piece sub alpha is a coefficient
let's say this is of degree 2d
it doesn't have to be actually even but
let's say 2d
any such polynomial can be represented
right by a symmetric matrix
okay
non-uniquely they're given more than one
symmetric matrix represents represents
means you put the symmetric matrix in
the middle
and then you have the monomial vector
of monomials of up to degree d if your
polynomial is to degree to d
and i just multiply it out right and we
know that this polynomial is a sum of
squares if and only if
the middle symmetric matrix is a is a
positive definite matrix
okay and such a matrix is called the
gram matrix
okay
of course you realize that
um if you if i give you a polynomial of
degree 2d and ask you is the sum of
squares
you can decide it
by checking the feasibility of a
semi-definite program
right the coefficients of your
polynomial
are written
as linear functions of the entries in
the q matrix
that gives you some affine constraints
and you want the q matrix to be positive
definite
that's exactly the feasible region of
nstp
yeah
and we can ask you know is this stp
feasible is the feasible set non-empty
or not
um
the feasible region of sachin
is for for for this problem right so we
stopped a polynomial yeah
um i'm going to call this gram
spectrohesion of that polynomial
so spectrohedron is a general
generalization of polyhedra
right um
polyhedra can be obtained by taking the
non-negative orton intersecting it with
that affine
nearest space
if you take the psd cone instead of the
non-negative orton and intersect the
verifying linear space
you get what's called a spectrogram
and these are special kinds of spectro
here
okay called the gram speaker and they
parametrize for a given p they
parameterize all possible ways of
writing this polynomial as a sum of
squares polynomial
okay it's a nice convex set
um
as a very very simple example okay
um here's a univariate polynomial of
degree two
okay you can ask is this a
sum of squares
well i presented for you a q matrix in
the middle there's one choice that could
be more choices
it turns out it's a psd matrix because i
can factor it as a times a transpose in
the middle
so it's sum of squares and here's the
sum of squares representation
as i said there could be more
ways of doing that and the totality of
all of those is the gram spectra for
this polynomial
okay um
so the big question is um for various
reasons we should study the geometry of
of spectra here in general
to understand seven different programs
in particular gram spectro here
okay the analogy here is that you know
what has been going on for almost 70
years now
when people study polyhedra for the
purpose of linear programming or integer
programming
right we know a lot more about polyhedra
and they help us for solving
optimization problems that we should be
able to do that now for these more
general objects
it's but this this work is in infancy
okay so they're kind of new people not
have been i mean people have been
studying but not you know big results
yet
not necessarily this is definitely not
for general spectrohydra
and you as you will see for even
graham's picture here that is sort of
our we're just just just slowly crawling
yeah
um
okay
so let me sort of tell you
to show you one thing that what i mean
by studying the geometry
okay
so let's take this uh
binary section yeah this is a polynomial
homogeneous in two variables of degree
six such a binary 6x can be uh presented
by telling you six coefficients
okay so the coefficient of one of the
monomers x to the sixth over y to six we
can assume to be one
okay and everything else is whatever you
want yeah
so if i ask you if you want to decide
whether this polynomial is a pst or not
um sorry sum of squares or not okay you
have to construct a skew matrix
and the q matrix in the middle has to
look like that
okay
so as you see that it has entries a1
through a6 coming from the polynomial
and then it has three other entries x1
x2 x3
so there is like a three-dimensional
space of representations
okay if i want this polynomial to sos i
want this matrix to be positive
semi-definite
okay some for some choice of x1 x2 x3
okay
so if i pick one choice of a1 through a6
some real numbers
i sort of i say oh i hope that it's a
a sum of squares polynomial
if that's so
here is that it's grams picture here
okay so it's a
three-dimensional object it's convex
it's a comics body it looks like a
puffed up
pillow okay
or like a
samosa okay
um
and uh yeah so so what i understand sort
of it's a very simple object but at the
[ __ ] at this moment we want to
understand this thing geometrically yeah
uh
like here let me tell you
you know what coming what we can say
about this kind of stuff
um
so here's is something they're fairly
new
uh it's a theorem and a corollary
actually by klaus scheider okay
says the following if you have
a
a homogeneous
positive binary sexting okay
um i'm not sure whether you know this or
not but
uh hilbert's a long time ago has
classified
polynomials real polynomials um which
are non-negative if and only if they are
sum of squares
okay sum of squares implies
non-negativity overs
but the reverse is not true
and then gilbert has this classification
and in the case of binary
okay homogeneous polynomials they are
equivalent
so instead of saying sos i can say
positive or non-negative there
okay so suppose you have one of those
and you look at the gram spectrohedron
that's g plus f okay as you saw in the
earlier picture it's a three-dimensional
convex body
okay
and in the inside corresponds to
matrices that have the four by four
matrices of rank four
okay in the interior
on the on the boundary okay this
spectrohedron it does not have any faces
of dimension one or two
okay it doesn't have patches of it
doesn't have these
line segments or curved segments
or or two-dimensional patches as faces
okay
moreover it's a big question to decide
whether whether the sum of squares
polynomial
how many how many squares do you need to
write the sum of squares polynomial yeah
and that's given by the rank
of the points inside so the lower the
better right
and in this in for the for the binary 60
case
the uh
on the boundary okay or on the inside
even the uh gram spectrum has points
okay
uh
can have points of rank two
okay we know in general generic it's
going to have exactly four
could have a little lower two okay um
and moreover yeah there's a sort of a
interesting corollary
if you have
two of those rank two matrices on the
boundary
okay you can draw the line segment
between them
that's in the gram spectrohedron but it
never lies on the boundary itself
okay it's in the interior
and if you sort of i don't know what
your intuition is but if you start think
about it the first time i thought about
i said well it should be true in general
yeah
but as you will see it's not true okay
and that's what i mean by studying the
geometry of these objects
so
um
just a little result you know it says
that if you have a binary sextic okay um
these rank two matrices
okay on the spectrohedron
um they can be read off
from the roots of this binary sexting
okay so minus six has six roots all
complex
okay and they come in conjugates of
conjugate pairs
if you look at them
by looking at those you can write down a
condition that says that those four rank
four
matrices that are on the boundary okay
can actually lie on a hyperplane
okay so
so that's a generic picture
there are four sort of typical points
here
that they correspond to rank two
matrices
okay in general they form a tetrahedron
if i take the common xl
but under this very special condition
they could lie on one hyperplane without
the spectra being two-dimensional still
three-dimensional
okay
so that's what i mean by studying
geometry here is another example so
let's go one more degree up yeah let's
look at binary optics degree eight
polynomials
so in that case we know okay that there
are eight rank two
matrices on the boundary
okay four six six plus four for octaxes
eight
um i'll tell you the general version
soon
so if you look at every pair of them
and then look at the line segment
between them
it turns out those line segments
actually lie on the boundary
now of the spectra
they're not in the interior anymore
and it's very weird that
16 of them 16 pairs
they lie on the boundary and they form
an edge a one dimensional face of the
spectrohedron
now 12 more 12 pairs they do not
they do lie on the boundary but they do
not make an edge
okay and moreover these
16 edges and then eight vertices or
eight matrices
make up a graph okay which is isomorphic
to the k44
so it's really interesting to try to
understand this kind of uh
geometry yeah
um so here's sort of uh wanting to do
uh as a and on top of that so let's take
a again a generic you know uh binary
optic uh sum of squares what we can do
is we can take the convex out
of those eight rank two uh matrices
okay
you get a polar top
inside the spectrohedron
this polar top happens to be always a
simplistic prototype
is one neighborly meaning every vertex
is connected to any other vertex through
an edge
okay and there could be many
combinatorial types of this popup but in
this particular case there are only two
combinatorial types
okay
in particular as opposed to the earlier
uh sextic case
you can never make those eight vertices
lie on a hyperplane
um
so
and you know we have some more journals
us in this in this in this direction for
for binary forms
but this sort of suggests that is there
a way of comparing this polytope this is
inside spectrum versus the spectrohidden
yeah how close they are
yeah
and the intuition is that as the
as the number of
as a degree increases yeah they sort of
get close to each other more and more
okay so that's what i mean by geometry
yeah
so let me switch gears so
this workshop is about optimization and
symmetry yeah
so um here what i'm going to do now is
i'm going to take
um
this could be any group really but i'm
going to do this for the symmetric group
only for you
the symmetric group of course acts
on the polynomial ring and variables of
degree d yeah the polynomials by
permuting the indices of the variables
okay that's a the natural action
that is a vector space of dimension
capital n which is the binomial
coefficient m plus d minus one choose d
yeah
so imagine you have orthogonal
representation
okay for this action of your symmetric
group
so they are given by these d sigmas yeah
orthogonal matrices
what we can do is we can look at what we
call the fixed point subspace
of symmetric matrices
okay so that's either s and to the sn so
these are symmetric matrices n by n
symmetric matrices capital n by cable
and symmetric matrices
okay which are
which commute with all of the
representation matrices
okay
so why would you do that well it turns
out that
this kind of matrices in the fixed point
subspace
okay
they represent
all symmetric polynomials
so you remember every polynomial
represented by symmetric matrix
if the polynomial is symmetric
okay there's always a q
from this fixed point subspace
right
okay
so
great so now comes an interesting thing
you know that you would expect from
representation theory
so if you take your
if you take your
um fixed point subspace
okay
then there exists what's called a
symmetry adapted basis there is a change
of basis
t okay
such that every matrix q in your
symmetric
in this uh in this subspace can be
represented in this block diagonal form
okay so the q lambda one true etc these
are symmetric matrices themselves
okay
and they are grouped
according to let me understand maybe
according to the irreducible
representations
of your of your group
in this case a symmetric group
okay so q lambda 1 these are symmetric
matrices
and the size of the symmetric means is
equal to the multiplicity of the
corresponding representation
there is a representation and the number
of copies you see is the dimension of
the relationship representation
okay so it really
if i look at this you know particular
subset
of q's symmetric matrices things sort of
get easy
okay
so
how could it be useful
so let's take a another example this
example is saying let's take a
binary
quartic which happens to be symmetric
okay ask ourselves is this sos
yeah
we can just forget about it's being
symmetric and then do it straightforward
way yeah
so in the middle there's a three by
three matrix but if you see it's
actually symmetric
then the cumulative can be more
specialized
okay so i can pick you from the
from the symmetry
uh from the fixed point subspace
and they in this say is that two
variables so s2 is acting
yeah a matrix q is going to be in the
fixed point subspace if it's symmetric
along the normal diagonal
but also it has to be symmetric along
the
anti-diagonal
okay which means that you know that
certain entries i color-coded them they
have to be all equal to each other
so you reduce the number of variables
on top of it you have this t the the
change of basis and all of a sudden your
matrix is going to look like much much
nicer let's block diagonal form so if i
want to test but this matrix is
positive semi-definite
you can test the blocks
which are smaller
okay
so by the way this is nothing new you
know people have thought about these
things
much before
um but now what we can say is now the
following okay let's say i'm interested
in the in the symmetric
uh polynomials that happens to be sos
okay what i can do now is
i can look at the the fixed point sub
space
okay those symmetric matrices that are
fixed under this action
and which happen to be psd
okay so i'm going to call that the ps
the symmetry adapter pst cone
similarly if i give you a symmetric
matrix um symmetric polynomial
i can look at the symmetry that the gram
spectrohedron
okay so those are the that's the grams
vector intersected with the fixed point
subspace
something much hopefully nicer and
smaller
okay so here's a picture to represent
this
okay so
uh the the plane is the
the vector space of symmetric matrices
of your choice
the blue cone is the pst cone
the green hyperplane is a hyperplane
given by by a polynomial maybe yeah you
intersect and you get the green ellipse
that's the the gram spectra here
okay but then comes this hyperplane
that's sort of a grayish
greenish hyperplane which is a fixed
point subspace
i intersect
the intersection of the pst cone is
another sort of this corner right there
that's the symmetry adapter pst cone
okay and if you intersect it with
further with the grams picture here then
you get that red line segment which is a
symmetry adapted um gram spectra hidden
much smaller much nicer
okay
so
okay so if that's thicker so what can we
say now with those this easier object
as i said this can be done for other
finite groups too but i'm just telling
you for the symmetric group
the first thing is
some structural results about the
the symmetry of the pst cone
okay
so the dimension of the
is that sum of those binomial
coefficients but m lambda i
is the
the multiplicity of the reducible
component corresponding to lambda i okay
what's your symmetric group
so it reduces as i said
uh moreover the extreme rays
of your ps of the cement at the pst cone
are determined by the rank one matrices
in each block
remember they look like this
like these blocks
okay if you want to get a
extreme rate you have to pick like this
is one block two lambda one block maybe
you pick a rank one matrix there and
then zero matrices otherwise
yes five minutes yep
okay
um which is in contrast to the usual psd
con right the pst cones
extreme rays are always corresponding to
rank 1 matrices
in this case
you can arrange it to be
that the extreme rates are going to be
more than rank 1 matrices
it's a nice structure there but
you just have to be careful
so let me let me give you a few examples
yeah what how how it can be used let's
take for instance a symmetric ternary
cortex
okay three variables degree four but
symmetric
such a polynomial can be given by four
coefficients really yeah you don't need
too many coefficients
so that's a b c d
that's a symmetric ternary coordinate
okay
if you do that yeah if i'm looking at
the symmetry adapted psd code maybe i'm
sorry let's make that the grams picture
here
okay it turns out that
it's only two-dimensional
it's small
and it's given by sort of the two p in
two pieces
yeah
and you have to intersect these two
spectrohedral on the plane and what are
those spectra here
they are given by actually one
uh
parabola and its interior
and a hyperbola and you pick one branch
of it and then it's interior
okay
so this is
um binary
no what was it these are symmetric
ternary cortex
if you erase the metric and if you look
at the general spectra here then it's
much more complicated
in particular for instance let me tell
you this okay if you take your
f to be positive symmetric ternary
quartic
in general if you forget that that's a
symmetric the corresponding grams
picture here it could have okay up to 63
uh rank three matrices on it
and that's the lowest you can get and
that's 63. there's a very beautiful
algebraic geometry behind this
okay but when you do symmetric only
three of them
can survive
they could be complex and two of them
are
pst
okay and those are those intersection
points those are the vertices you see
there those two
okay
so what you should imagine here is that
i told you the
um
where was that oh no no binary six that
was different i didn't give you a
picture of turner cortex whatever yeah
um
so you can still tell a lot more okay
because they are simpler objects
um
let me see
so here's another one this is symmetric
binary 666. you remember i told you the
non-symmetric version
it was this uh like a tetrahedron like
object okay if insist that's symmetric
okay
then
it's again two-dimensional
okay and this time it's intersection of
two parabolas
okay it could have up to four rank two
vertices
so what you should imagine is that
we have the
what was that here the puffed up guy
yeah
you intersect this with the symmetry
the the fixed point sub space
and the resulting object is those
intensities of these two parabolas
okay so
almost done
let me let me finish with the with the
following two observations and two
results
if you look at general's binary forms
yeah
i already tell you about uh the cortex
no sex takes an optics right
there is a general characterization of
those points on the spectrohedron not
the symmetry adapter the usual one okay
uh
of those points which are off rank two
okay
and these rank two representations can
be figured out from the roots
some partition of the roots of your
polynomial
and they're always two to the d minus
one of them
okay
and as i said like what we can do is you
can take the common xl of these guys and
then compare to
the the spectre here
okay so this sort of a classic theorem
okay but we can now extend this in the
symmetric case
yeah
so if you had the symmetric binary form
of degree 2d
hey we can tell exactly how many of
those rank 2 matches we're going to
survive when you intersect with the
fixed points up space
yeah
so if d is even and 2 to the d or 2 is
surviving and if it's odd to the d minus
1 over 2 it's arriving
okay and then it's not just a number by
the way we can precisely characterize
which ones are going to survive by
looking at the roots again
so it's like a nice generalization of a
very classic theorem
um
maybe i'll
i'll briefly say something like you know
uh ternary 6 is a big spectrohidden high
dimensional
oh we don't we almost not know nothing
about
it we can look at the symmetric version
of that
it's a 10 by so the q matrix are 10 by
10
and it sort of broke it up if you if you
look at the symmetry adapted basis it's
broken up into four pieces
okay one can hope to sort of do
something with this
but even then it's difficult yeah so we
don't have much to say yet at least
but you can now do some simulations for
instance yeah
you can say hey you know if i look at
the points on the boundary
and collect sort of uh classify the
ranks of the matrices what do you get if
i do randomly
okay so we did some simulations as you
can see so those four five six seven
eight those are the possible ranks
hey you know there's there's not much of
a pattern but you need something like
for instance most of the time you get
you get uh
in most examples you get rank six the
most yeah
and it's not again it'd be nice sort of
to give explanations for these things
from a geometric point of view
let me stop there take questions
yeah hi yes so how do you
so in all your theorems you have that
you're requiring your binary form to
have distinct roots yes
yeah so can you tell a little bit what
happens when the the roots are the same
so what happens to the spectroheater if
that yeah so then the the spectration
basically degenerates to a speculation
of a lower degree
uh binary form
if yeah so let's say you know if you're
let's say it was degree 10 yeah
and if uh
some roots coincided
yeah then you can sort of factor out
that piece
okay and then you look at the remaining
part
of your polynomial and then that's what
you look at and that gives you still
spectral hidden but the lower
dimensional for a lower degree uh
symmetric polynomial
oh i see so then like in a sense this
result is in a way general because
yes anything else like if you have the
same roots you can reduce it too that's
right
yeah it's done there's no surprises if
you don't have the same roots
oh but then what happens if you have
like two sets of roots that are the same
but like
let's say i have degree
10 and i have two roots that are the
same and one and then two roots are the
same in the other way this is different
than
having
like just one set of the same roots is
you you can still degenerate to like
smaller
say but i mean i understand the
conditions so if you have yeah let's say
you have like two roots one and then two
roots two
right so you have you can still like
reduce this it doesn't matter that it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter oh yeah
doesn't matter
yeah okay why why is that sorry
i'm not immediate to me
um
because if you have the um repeated root
right
that piece of the so if you factor out
that is this
that's already a square
that polynomial yeah
and i can
whatever is left is is governing the
rest yeah oh yeah because these are kind
of like
yeah yeah and it doesn't have to be i
mean this doesn't have to symmetric any
you know any polynomial will work right
right so you just care about the
irregularity
um have you looked at the case when f is
not an sos but i don't know lives in
some quadratic module
have you carried out the same analysis
no no you think it's much harder or i
think it's harder yes okay yeah um so if
this what you asked has not been done
like even for the binary forms for the
in general case even i have not i have
not seen much of it
if there is you know one should look at
it and then try to generalize it for a
symmetric case
have you considered like a fourth order
tensors do the same thing as like doing
these outer products no no no also all i
mean it's so much to uh
to do uh it's really start right now
yeah yeah yeah no i have not no not
today it's a good question
any other questions in the chat maybe oh
yeah yeah
no
okay well then let's thank speaker again
thank you thank you